that that thing called out what if she
didn't have a dad like my Apple it goes
to the shop and don't come back you know
I mean that what if she didn't have a
dad like how would you look but that
also tells me of course look I'm not
saying it's her
's ability there I understand it's not
her fault but it is her responsibility
and it may be like while I was young
whatever okay fine my responsible for
that thank you
for your life
I know you're not responsible for that
but even when I hear you talk like you
you sort of blame it on everyone else
but you but you kind of you kind of
blame like your situation and like this
is like like instead of It's My Life
Choices